non alors déjà je voulais quand même
vous dire que c'est extrêmement décevant
et compliqué pour nous c'est de se
retrouver confronté à ça non mais ça il
faut le dire moi je suis avec des
équipes qui travaillent sur ce programme
depuis 20 ans ce légende ça a été
énormément de travail pour nous il ya
300 personnes qui se déplacent il faut
savoir qu'il ya des gens qui restent
jusqu'à 75 jours quand même sans manger
en famille non sans voir leur famille
bon je travaillais sur koh-lanta et que
pour nous réunir autant de générations
d'aventuriers bien sûr été c'est un défi
et c'était on va là ont misé éléments là
dessus il ya aucun moment on a pensé
qu'on pouvait se retrouver face à moi
des gens qui disent que sa cote de la
production parce que tous les candidats
même claude on l'a entendu hier dans une
loge et tous les candidats que c'est
mieux il dit sa cause la production mais
alors savez j'ai entendu combat la
dernière fois alors je suis fan de one
on me mets moi elle sait que je les aime
bien combat aussi donc c'est pour ça que
ça me dit que vous êtes en amont où
j'aimais tout est tellement c'est
tellement facile de se défausser vous
explique comment ça se passe on a des
aventuriers pourcentage ont fait jusqu'à
quatre à cinq éditions déjà de koh lanta
c'est des gens qui connaissent
parfaitement ce programme c'est des gens
qui sont respectés qu'ils sont adulés
pour certains par des enfants par des
plus âgés et qui connaissent layrac de
loyauté du programme alors on n'est pas
vous l'avez dit nous mêmes et vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs nous ne sommes pas
des procureurs nous ne sommes pas des
freak on a mis un système de
surveillance d'autant plus qu'on savait
qu'on était en polynésie c'est l'une des
rares fois on a tourné justement sur un
territoire français d'habitude on tour
et roger donc évidemment à l'étranger
les gens ne connaissent pas tromper les
personnalités ne connaissent même pas le
programme là en l'occurrence pour des
histoires de vie dont on est obligé de
tourner en polynésie donc on a renforcé
la sécurité mais on est comme sur un
principe de confiance c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas gardien de on n'est pas
gardien de prison ouais donc que l'on
soit trahi comme ça ne nous trompons pas
on est victime de ça on l'a appris nous
au moment de l' annonce de theora donc
il ya trois semaines à moi on est tombé
des nues quoi donc il faut il faut des
contrôles quand il dit ça cause la
production parce qu'il aurait dû le plus
nous surveiller vous dites quoi mais
enfin c'est non mais c'est c'est comme
si alors vous savez on est tous des
truands donc vous le saviez qu'on était
des truands et donc vous auriez mettre
des gardiens plus aguerris mais on avait
des gars des rebonds on ne les a jamais
prêt pour détruire pour nous c'est des
légendes donc il ya un moment il faut
pas se tromper donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est dans un cas il faut savoir les
équipes chez moi c'est ultra violent il
paraît que vous êtes très déçu de cette
dispute cette saison il n'a pas déçu de
la saison en ce moment c'est à dire de
ce qui s'est passé on a battu des
records incroyable parce que quand même
il ya il faut pas il faut pas tout jeter
enfin le lot c'est quoi c'est bien le
bébé avec l'eau du bain bébé avec l'eau
du bain viacom a eu des records me
demander comment ces
noms mais je sais je sais vous êtes un
peu le la le lin coulisses on n'a plus
de sens et donc non mais c'est vrai il
ya eu des records incroyables qui ont
été battus je pense au cochon pendu
bryan 6 personnes qui ont battu des
records c'est vrai ça voilà il ya eu sur
la proue enfin mollasson il était le
mort ce qu'a gagné donc a eu des choses
incroyables et des revirements de la
stratégie des choses fantastiques donc
ce alors une très belle saison mais mais
sincèrement oui je le reconnais à jos et
terni cette saison c'est bien le dire
alaxia oui
alexia pourquoi vous avez pas évoquer la
triche ah bon alors pourquoi on n'a pas
évoqué
avant quoi avant les romains non mais
c'est vrai 22h43 oui avance sur le prime
bah oui mais voilà les vrais cracks de
plusieurs points premier point et ça on
l'a dit et on a communiqué sur nos
réseaux sociaux on ne veut pas donner
non d'accord c'est à dire qu'on sait moi
je voulais donner moi je dis non non
mais voilà on sait on a suffisamment de
preuves et d'épreuves réellement fondées
on a un constat une attestation
d'huissier et je voulais apporter parce
que il faut savoir que comme si la
machine
non mais c'est important c'est donc à
consommer du règlement jeu ce que je
sais que vous avez règlement du jeu est
déposé ses maîtres simonin en
l'occurrence moyens à un moment quand
jacques ans j'ai rassemblé 1,1 un
certain nombre de preuves je suis allé
le voir et je lui dis est-ce que vous
pour vous ça constitue une rupture du
code d'honneur qui est inscrit dans le
règlement du jeu et là il me dit je vous
lis l'attestation c'est important parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est revenue
à l'éthiopien qui est extérieur à la
production qui est extérieur à tf1 qui
est neutre le show et qui est garant du
règlement donc monsieur simona confirmé
atteste avoir reçu l'ensemble des pièces
et éléments permettant d'établir le
comportement irrégulier de plusieurs
participants lors du déroulé du jeu
l'ensemble de ces pièces illustre les
moments où code d'honneur et l éthique
générale est exposée dans le règlement
du jeu qui est déposé en mon étude et
justifie l'impossibilité de déclarer un
vainqueur pour cette saison donc ça
c'est au premier poteau